We called this talk
"The Making of Meru"
to try to give you
guys some insight on how
a story like this,
you know
a climb like this of rather
epic, historic proportions
can be translated into a
film for a general audience
that may have absolutely
no knowledge of climbing.
I started working
on this project
not really thinking about
making a feature documentary.
It was really just about
shooting for posterity.
And when I finally had a chance
to watch what Jimmy had
sent me, I was just
struck this material, I'd never
seen anything like it before.
And what was so special
about this material
is unique to Jimmy and Renan
and their particular skill-set
where they are
professional climbers
and also professional shooters.
And it was just...
like, how visceral the footage
was, how authentic it was
really moved me.
The shooting on it
was certainly
one of the obvious
great challenges.
Some expeditions are
really based on the production
where the
production kind of
almost finances or
funds the trip
and it's really about shooting
and coming back with a story.
This climb was the opposite.
This climb was about the climb,
it wasn't about the shooting.
And you approach it
very differently.
We had, you know,
400 yaks and
a huge team when we went
to Everest to shoot
"The Wildest Dream".
And on this climb
it was Renan and I
shouldering each a small
camera, and so...
it really made it kind
of the ultimate challenge
as kind of a filmmaker for...
expedition shooting, so...
there's a ton of
shots that we missed
and I try not to dwell
on those too much but
( audience laughter )
And, you know
in the documentary world
if you didn't get it
it didn't happen, so...
you know, then you're
juggling that pressure.
I mean, just a zillion
details here that, you know
they're not backing
up their footage
they're bringing a
finite amount of cards
up on the mountain, alright
they have no batt--
like no way to charge
their batteries.
And so, weight is a real issue
but I can't, you know,
as a documentary filmmaker
I can't conceive of not being
able to back-up my footage.
And not-- and having a
finite amount of tape.
So, it just charges these shots
I mean--
it's a lot of pressure
and that's one of
the things that makes
the footage just so special.
A lot of the rules of
shooting go out the window.
Like, you're supposed to have a
head and a tail to every shot.
You know, so that there's
five seconds in front of it
in the beginning of the shot
and there's five or ten seconds
at the end of the shot
so the editor has
some space to cut.
But our shots don't
have heads and tails.
And when you watch it,
you know the...
it all-- 'cause you have
to hold your breath
when you're shooting up there
and it's really hard to
hold your breath up there.
So, all the heads and
tails go like this...
( inhales deeply )
( audience laughter )
And then the end of
the shot is like...
( exhales )
( audience laughter )
And they're like only 15
seconds long, this is no joke.
I mean,
we'd sit in the edit room
we'd be like there must be more.
( audience laughter )
There must be more.
You know, like, we... it...
I don't know, it was...
It posed this, you had these
like kind of jewels of footage
yet with some very real-like
narrative constraints around it
where there just
wasn't that much.
No, it was classic because we'd
be sitting in the editing room
and everybody would be
glued to the screen
and we'd be watching this clip
and it'd be like this great,
great clip
and everybody is excited
and then it would end
and then everybody
would look at me.
( audience laughter )
And I'd be like, "Well, let
me explain something to you.
We're at 20,000 feet, I'm
like trying to stack the rope
because Conrad's basically
starting to get to the point
where like,
"You're still shooting?
You should be stacking the rope.
You should be
re-racking the gear."
But that's hard to
explain to your editor
when you're trying
to make a film.